Hello Freak bitches.
What comes to ball?
What's the effect on my mind of looking at my Twitter ad mentioned?
So I wondered that when you were asking people what kind of questions they said,
yeah,
we should ask what we'll send this podcast.
Sometimes it's incredibly useful.
I was thinking of what you're doing.
You're opening yourself up to the green frog.
Yeah.
But I've had both kinds of experience.
I've,
I've had people send me articles that I would have never found otherwise are
fascinating and super useful and it's just a,
it's like this is the perfect use of this technology.
And then again,
then I,
then I get this river of green frogs and weirdness.
Um,
but the,
to the previous point,
I pay attention to something for long stretches of time rather than do in
something I know is good for me with my attention.
I kind of spin the roulette wheel with,
with Twitter and rather often there's just this kind of toxic undercurrent of,
of,
you know,
mental activity that it produces in me that,
um,
I mean doesn't make me feel,
I mean,
it doesn't equip me to do anything better in my life.
It doesn't make me feel any better about myself or other people.
I mean,
if it,
if it has any net effect,
it's,
it basically grabbed a dozen dials that I can just sort of dimly conceive of in
my mind and turn them all a little bit toward the negative.
You know,
I feel a little bit worse about myself,
a little bit worse about my career,
a little bit worse about people,
a little bit,
a little bit worse about the future.
Little bit worse about the fact that I just was doing this when I could have
been playing with my kid or,
or writing or thinking productive thoughts or meditating or doing so.
You still do,
you still do this?
I still check Twitter compulsion.
Yeah.
You,
you argue with people.
I found that fascinating.
Yeah.
Not,
don't I go,
I go for,
I go for weeks without argument.
People.
Well,
but also you argue with people on your podcast.
yeah,
but that's right.
That's different.
No,
no,
but I mean it,
just on the podcast you'll also be talking about people you're arguing with on
Twitter or so the arguing is a part of your,
well,
I get trolled a lot on Twitter.
I get trolled.
I mean,
you have guests,
you have guests who come on your podcast and savage me on the podcast and then
troll me endlessly on Twitter and like Abby,
Abby Martin.
Well she was,
no,
she doesn't show it.
I mean she,
she,
she hates me,
but she,
I don't,
I haven't noticed her trolling me.
But now you got in a room with her.
Everybody would calm down.
She just has,
there's people that have radical misconceptions of who you are.
I'm sure you heard the Josh steps,
Patton Oswald thing or Patton Oswald.
Don't,
don't listen to it because he went off the rem pod,
went off the rails,
like,
like Hannibal style went off.
Are you thinking of Andy Kindler?
Oh yes.
Okay.
I'm sorry,
did I say Patton Oswald?
I'm so sorry.
That's good.
So sorry.
Oswaldo patents.
Great,
good.
Well,
very smart and very reasonable as is Andy for the most,
most of the time.
But so,
so then he's kind of crazy and discover this very late.
I did.
So I kept seeing this guy.
I didn't know who he was.
I kept seeing him in my Twitter feed,
Andy kindler and they can learn.
Then I realized,
wait a minute,
he is actually,
he seems to be,
I mean,
he's established comic.
He seems to be friends with people who I really respect who I don't know,
like,
you know,
I mean Sarah Silverman,
who I,
I don't know personally.
I mean we've,
we've communicated a little bit on Twitter,
but it's like,
I,
I'm just nothing but a pure fan of,
of Sarah,
uh,
Jim Gaffigan,
other big comics.
So I totally respect,
I don't know how close he is with these people,
but he basically,
he has endless energy for vilifying me as a racist and as a bigot.
Right?
I mean,
he's just,
he's a madman.
And I discovered,
so I did a search of his Twitter feed and he's got hundreds and hundreds of
tweets where he's,
he's going after me and the most retail way.
So for instance,
like I tweeted out a,
can anyone recommend 500 seat halls and all these cities and I think your friend
is Duncan Trussell,
a friend of yours.
Okay.
So Duncan wrote back saying,
Oh yeah,
Dma,
I've got a great place in Boston or something.
And then Andy kindler jumped in to that thread talking to Duncan saying,
don't help him Duncan,
he's a bigot.
Right?
So like he's like,
this is Andy Kindler is just got endless energy for this.
And then I,
then I looked at,
you know,
what he was doing and he had been doing it for years and I wasn't aware of it
just to you,
just to me and Bill Maher,
he's still more,
but then you've got another guy on this podcast.
Hunter mats had him on one.
Okay.
So he was on here and I actually had to go back and watch what he said here
because I had been getting so much of this on Twitter.
And I mean it's incredibly common.
People are tweeting at me saying,
why won't you debate a hunter?
It's mats,
right?
Why won't you debate hunter masks?
I went back and looked at what he said here.
You know,
half of it frankly didn't make any sense.
Um,
but his attacks on the,
on Twitter are the most juvenile.
It's like the idea that he thinks this is a way he's going to establish a
conversation with me by sending me to tweets and then sending me 400 which say,
you're scared to debate me.
Right?
It's crap.
I mean,
I think he,
I don't know,
very,
very smart guy,
but taking a terrible socially retarded approach to establishing a debate.
And I've contacted Brian Cowen about this and Brian Cowen contacted hunter about
this and was like,
what the fuck are you doing?
And he continues to do it.
Is that crazy behavior?
He said he wouldn't do it anymore.
And then he did it with more,
I mean,
every time I look,
I,
I see him somewhere in there.
And,
but then,
then there's this guy,
Mike Cernovich,
who,
who's actually has effects on the real world.
I mean,
Mike Cernovich is again,
he said Twitter troll.
Um,
again,
one of these other guys who's challenged me to debate him.
And I,
you know,
I mean there's,
there's,
there's no,
there's absolutely no possibility of dialogue.
Yeah.
Listen,
Cernovich just was just on 60 minutes.
I mean,
he's like,
he's in the world and he's affecting people's conception of Trump psyche.
Oh yeah.
Well,
okay,
sure.
Right?
Yes.
So they could come back.
Is it,
it's not,
the nine times out of 10 looking just makes me think,
um,
I mean,
it's an illusion because if you met most of these people,
if you,
if they came up to you at a conference or at a,
you know,
book sign in her,
so,
you know,
after a Gig of yours and you saw,
you had more information about them,
you saw all of the,
you know,
all of the crazy coming out.
Um,
you would say,
I don't have to pay any time.
There's no reason to pay attention to what this guy is saying.
Whereas on Twitter,
everything is how has the same stature.
So whether it's,
you know,
a Washington Post columnist who's tweeting at me or some,
some guy like hunter who,
you know,
I had,
I have no idea who he is,
but he's telling me I've got something wrong.
Um,
everything has the same stature and you just,
there's no signal to noise sense of what you know.
Well first of all,
you fucked up cause you talked about them both.
Well you said candy man five times and now you've got a problem and you talked
about him right now on this page,
this is the first time I've ever mentioned,
but I'll go in and talk to you before that I'm bringing,
I'm bringing it to you because you,
you,
you created it.
I mean it was,
it was,
it was his,
it was his podcast with you.
They kicked this whole thing.
Oh I didn't think that a hundred was going to do that.
And I know for a fact that hunter is actually a fan of yours.
I think what hunter's trying,
he's got a strange way of showing it.
I don't think it's a smart way.
I think what he's trying to do,
and he,
when I was trying to hold his feet to the fire and get some sort of a logical
definition of what you do wrong,
he really didn't have anything.
But he's willing,
but he thinks he does.
And he,
but did he,
when I talked to him about it and no,
no.
And half of what he said about Dawkins and me was totally wrong and have what he
said about the,
the relevant biology was wrong.
I mean he's just,
he's not,
he doesn't have his shit together,
but he thinks he does.
And there's this,
there's a,
there's a level of,
of arrogance and,
and in civility and just kind of a lack of charity in,
in interacting with other people's views,
which is now kind of getting rebranded on the Internet as just just American can
do Chutzpah.
Right.
And it's like,
it's given us Trump,
right?
It's like you've got a,
Trump is the ultimate example.
He's like the cartoon version of,
you know,
a person who doesn't know anything relevant to the enterprise,
who doesn't show any,
uh,
aptitude for civilly engaging with differences of opinion.
And this thing gets amplified to the,
to the place of greatest prominence.
Now in human history,
everyone's on social media or many people on social media are playing the same
game.
And,
you know,
Ms Cernovich's and another,
just malignant example of this where you have someone who's got a fairly large
following.
I mean,
it's not as big as yours,
but it's,
you know,
it's,
it's a very engaged following the,
I mean,
this whole Trump phenomenon has,
has,
uh,
shown me that Pete,
that if a small percentage of,
of one's audience can have like a hundred times the energy of the rest of your
audience.
Like whenever I went against Trump on my podcast or is,
is still the case,
the,
the level of,
of pain it causes in,
in the sort of the feedback space is completely out of proportion to the numbers
of people who are,
who are,
um,
you know,
on that side of the argument.
And it's so,
it's incredibly energized,
but it's just this weird style of self promotion where you,
all you do is that you brag about yourself,
you say you're the best,
your [inaudible],
you're,
you're someone who has absolutely no basis to back up those claims.
And yet,
and audience thrills to that level of arrogance and an empty boast.
It's
just bizarre.
But,
well,
there's a,
there's a big issue I think online where people find likeminded people and then
they develop these communities where they just support each other and they just
have these,
these gigantic groups of people.
I mean,
not even necessarily gigantic,
but groups of people that find any subject.
Like for me,
you know what it is flat earth,
right?
I get trolled by people all day that claim I'm a sellout because I don't believe
the earth is flat.
Mr Is real.
But don't think that there's a,
there's a,
I think this phenomenon that you're describing is both,
um,
has really serious negative consequences,
but it also has some beauty on the same.
By the same token,
you've got parents,
uh,
all over the world who've got children with a rare disease,
but they can connect on the internet and bond over that and share tips and
doctors.
So it is,
it's actually,
they're both outgrowths of the same kind of phenomenon,
but he can be,
we see the,
the really difficult,
uh,
consequences of this in our politics right now,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
I think we're talking about two different things.
You think so?
I'm
talking about confirmation bias.
I'm talking about a bunch of people that get together and say,
yeah,
obviously,
uh,
I'm woke and the earth is flat and pay attention is an odd analogy allowing ice
ball.
Yes.
But there are different things.
The groups of people that will find communities where maybe your child has
autism and there's some sort of an issue,
uh,
that can be mitigated with diet.
And parents have had some success with that and they could give you some
enlightening information and you can communicate with each other.
And that's nice.
It's beautiful.
And I'm some of the hashtags that people use that they've,
they find search through,
it's great,
but you know that these little communities that you bond,
that they're not,
that's those,
those ideas.
There's no confirmation bias and those ideas.
But there's confirmation bias and the idea that Trump is,
man,
there's confirmation bias and the idea that the earth is flat,
you know,
and if you just huddle in those little communities and just bark the same noises
that everybody else barks,
there's some sort of sense of community in that too.
Yes.
And people love that.
They love being a part of a fucking team.
Even if it's a stupid team of green frogs and you don't have love it.
You don't have to listen to other people's views and you get deeply,
deeply entrenched.
I think we're seeing,
we're seeing this all through our politics and media right now.
Well,
you also see when you go to those people's pages,
which I do
often,
I don't engage with people in a negative way online very often.
Very,
very rarely.
Do you not look at your ad mentions,
are you?
A little bit,
but do you know what man?
I just like to just go on about my day.
Yeah,
I've,
I've found that the negative consequences that you're discussing,
I mean I read,
I mean it's rare that I go down the rabbit hole and I go for days without
looking at ad mentioned.
I mean it's,
it's more that if I publish something,
if we are,
if I asked for feedback,
I want to see the feedback.
It's not necessarily useful.
There's anything,
well,
I mean,
just as your friend.
I mean I feel like there's nothing wrong with it.
I look at my app mentions,
but um,
but you,
you junction in a very different space.
I mean,
you're not pushing controversial stuff out there that definitely not.
Definitely not.
So I agree.
I stayed,
I'm fine.
I'm sorry,
go ahead.
I was just more worried about,
again,
health,
your psyche.
It's feels like you need a little bit of a middle.
Yeah.
I stay offline after UFC for the most part.
That's when I get the most crazy people,
especially if there's any sort of a controversial decision.
But there,
are they criticizing you for something you said or they get fucking mad at my
commentary.
They'll just disagree with who I thought water and been,
they're so fucking vicious about it.
I'm just like,
just yell.
Just yelling your own.
You don't want to see any of that.
There's too many people.
You're dealing with millions and millions of people and who knows how many of
them are rational when you're dealing with,
you know,
there's a bit that I had one of my specials where I was talking about the,
the number of people that are stupid in the world.
Like if you get a room full of a hundred people,
the idea that one person isn't a complete fucking idiot.
Of course you're being very charitable and being chairman one.
Yeah.
But if you do that,
we are talking about 300 million people in the United States.
Plus that's 3 million fucking idiots.
Yeah.
So if you have 3 million fucking idiots and all your ad mentions,
if you look at your ad mentions in 3 million comments are saying you're a
fucking moron.
And the just,
just too many people,
the numbers are,
they're not manageable.
The numbers of human beings you interact with online are not manageable.
So anytime anything gets negative or insulting,
and I just check out,
I just,
next,
I don't pay attention because you can't.
But if I fucked up and I know I fucked up,
I think one of the most important things that I do is I admit that I fuck you.
And I talk about it and I apologize and I say,
look,
I'm flawed.
I'm human.
I made a mistake.
Sorry.
And then just step away.
Let the fucking chaos and sue in the comments.
But all the people call you a shill and a whatever,
let all that happen.
But don't let in like
you're letting it in and then you stew on it and you have to bring up,
you know,
a hunter and all these other people and that's you.
You're letting them way too.
No,
no,
no.
I mean,
perhaps I gave a false impression of,
of how under my skin this has gotten,
just in fact,
he talked about it at all of those too much.
Well,
no,
but I th I think it's a huge consequence,
but I think it's given us Trump this way,
this,
this way.
The fact that this style of communication is attractive to so many people.
The fact that you can the bluff and bluster and empty boast and lies with being
caught in lies without consequence.
Um,
the fact that,
that,
that people never admit mistakes.
I mean the,
the,
you know,
what you just described to you,
you do.
And which I do,
you know,
you make a mistake,
you want to hear about it.
You want to correct it as quickly as possible.
Right?
That is the antithesis of what we're seeing now in this space.
I mean,
when has Trump admitted a mistake?
But isn't it the difference being that you,
neither you nor I have any desire to control anything.
Like I don't,
I don't want to be the leader of anything.
Well,
no,
but you want effective can you want good ideas to win and you want the truth to
win.
You want the truth to propagate what facts to propagate.
You want to be able to correct errors,
whether they're your own or others,
especially when they're consequential.
And I think that we need a,
we need a common ethic where lying has real consequences.
I mean,
what so many people are trying to figure out what's the antidote to fake news?
Well,
one antidote is to be caught.
Line has to be devastating for your career,
right?
Like it hit politically,
journalistically,
academically as a,
as a public intellectual,
I mean,
to be caught in a whopping lie without a will require at minimum,
some serious atonement.
And historically it has been so many,
we have slipped those rails just to,
to a degree that I had never thought possible.
We're going lightspeed right into the woods.
Yeah.
I mean,
we're talking about people have figured out how to,
just to use dishonesty as extra fuel.
I mean,
it's like,
you know,
the,
the blue whatever that the nitrous oxide boost in those,
the hacky cars,
right?
It's like we can use this stuff,
right.
And the getting the,
the way you behave when you get caught,
just,
Eh,
which is to say,
just go fuck yourself.
Just redounds to your credibility in your,
among your tribe.
Right.
It's like this guy is so powerful.
He,
he,
he so fully doesn't give a shit what people think that he can catch him in a lie
and just watch how he,
he gets out of it.
Um,
and,
but that's,
that's what I was bringing up these guys like Cernovich I mean this,
this is,
um,
I actually,
I,
I trolled Crna,
I decided to troll Cernovich one day and I,
I thought it was hilarious and I,
it was just nothing but fun.
So there was something toxic about that.
But,
but the thing that bothers me is that this has real political consequences.
And I,
you know,
do you think that this is a,
this is a time period where we're in the sort of adolescent stage of
communication online where you can get away with saying things that are
dishonest and that there might be some sort of a way to mitigate that in the
future.
There might be some,
I don't think we should act like dishonesty and bluff and bluster to use a
phrase you used before is started somehow knew,
did he?
Human Repertoire.
I get that.
The acceptance of it seems to be though I think we're in a period where that is
true and I think it did,
is aided and abetted by technology and the social networks.
I agree with your diagnosis on many levels,
but I,
you know,
it's having an interesting conversation with a guy that you introduced me to,
Joseph Goldstein,
who was,
uh,
eminent meditation teacher has become my meditation teacher,
old friend of Sam's.
And he was saying,
we were talking about the current political situation.
He used a phrase that I like when I was asked him what he thought about it.
He said,
I'm kind of slotting into geological time,
and I think that actually makes some sense.
Not to say that,
what does that mean?
Meaning that I'm just viewing it from a far,
I'm widening the Lens to look at the broad
scope of human history to see that,
you know,
over time we've got these ups and downs.
He's getting to the top of the mountain near Denver with a big bucket of
Margarita.
That's exactly right.
There's slotting in and sliding it.
Yeah.
Okay.